il ya quelques semaines on pourra
présenter pas moins de trois nouveaux
modèles pour renouveler sa gamme finepix
avec félix 2 series on a le finepix de
pro vous est présentée à
boulogne-billancourt est à quelques
bonnes semaines avant le confinement le
finepix de neo dont je vous ai parlé
également il ya quelques jours et
maintenant à parler du findings de
l'ajst une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec au pot pour vous
présenter le assez compliqué je n'avais
pas le plus petit modèle de la gamme
parce que c'est faux et archi faux
ça sera le moins suspects et des trois
bien évidemment mais c'est pas le plus
petit loin de là et d'ailleurs je trouve
à ce sujet que la dénomination light je
me permets au pot mais pour moi c'est
pas la bonne parce que light ça
sous-entend souvent smartphones d'entrée
et milieu de gamme
là on n'est pas sur un smartphone
d'entrée milieu de gamme on est sur un
bon milieu de gamme d'ailleurs cette
année ils ont sorti un smartphone milieu
de gamme un smartphone haut de gamme
avec le neo est un smartphone très haut
de gamme avec le pro donc c'est une
gamme qui est tiré vers le haut avec
plus de références aujourd'hui on se
concentre vraiment sur le finepix
delahaye qui n'a de light que le nom et
qui fait plein de belles promesses lors
la question qu'on va se pose aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que le finepix de light est
fait pour vous qu'est-ce qu'il peut vous
apporter à quoi il va vous servir alors
à téléphoner ça on s'en doutera utiliser
des applications mais quels sont ses
points forts qu elles sont également ses
faiblesses
quels sont les petites plus parce que
chez au pot est toujours un gros con
dans cette technologie et c'est ça qui
va choix intéressant aussi avec ce
smartphone là qui ne déroge pas à la
règle non plus mais avant toute chose et
si ce n'est pas déjà le cas je vous
invite à vous abonner parce que comme je
vous le dis oui bien évidemment je
présente toutes les nouveautés
smartphones on parle de plein de
technologies on parle de vos usages on
parle de vous de votre vie numérique je
vous invite donc à vous abonner dès
maintenant vous allez claque là que vous
cliquez juste en dessous ici vous
activer la cloche et c'est merveilleux
il n'y a pas de grosse différence entre
ce que vous allez avoir au niveau du pro
du néo et du light mais ce côté un peu
alvéolé avec un nom qui ressort comme ça
tout ça vraiment bien le fait d'avoir un
peu ce petit côté doré c'est très cool
ça harmonie cette gamme find x2 est
surtout un des points essentiels et vous
le voyez ici 5 g 5 g 5 g parce que oui
vous avez également de la 5g sur modèle
ait une fois de plus il n'a de light que
le nom à l'heure à laquelle je donc
cette vidéo en france en tout cas la 5g
n'est pas encore arrivé mais va arriver
dans les mois à venir
la 5g vous avez ici c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la 5 g n et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la nsa des états unis dès
qu'on pourrait la connaître non ici ça
veut dire non au stand alone par
opposition à la 5g stand-up vous faire
extrêmement simple la scène jane not
stand alone on part du réseau 4g sur
lequel on va rajouter des antennes 5 g
par opposition à la 5g standalone qui
est fonctionnel en autonomie et sans
dépendre du réseau 4g on oublie un peu
ses considérations techniques
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous avez
un smartphone qui est prêt pour la 5g
dès lors qu'elle sera arrivé en france
si vous êtes en france si vous êtes en
suisse elle est déjà arrivé donc si vous
l'achetez vous pourrez l'utiliser sans
aucun problème au delà de sarnaut
smartphones qui est très très très cool
et surtout parce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est se dit dégradé de couleurs c'est
toujours un peu délicat de le voir comme
ça que les éclairages là vous avez une
partie qui est vraiment bleus une partie
violine une partie qui tire sur le rose
ici je trouve ça vraiment super super
élégant pour coup c'est très
différenciant et ça lui apporte vraiment
quelque chose de particulier on a les
quatre caméras qui sont situés ici à la
verticale dans tout un cercle à ce qui
va lui apporter un côté un peu plus
premium
on a ici une encoche mon la bordure en
bas par contre assez proéminente on
retrouve d'un côté le bouton convient
l'allumé poète 1,2 à côté les boutons de
volume on va retrouver ce en dessous la
prise en usb c'est pour bien recharger
le haut parleur mono le micro la prise
jack
le micro pour la réduction de bruit bon
ça c'est un très très très grand
classique la prise en main est plutôt
bonne le capteur d'empreintes digitales
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement il
est dispo dans de couleur la couleur
vous avez là c'est le blanc polaire mais
vous avez également le noir lumière en
gros c'est aspirer du ciel jour nuit
vous l'aurez compris est ce un
smartphone qui est pas très lourd
puisqu'il pèse à peine 180 g du point de
vue purement esthétique je trouve que la
copie est vraiment réussi à avoir un bon
smartphone qui tient bien en main c'est
bien mais qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
les usages vous en douterez sont
multiples le tout premier ça avec la
question du multimédia et la question du
multimédia elle repose sur quatre
piliers essentiels le confort et la
qualité de visionnage avec l'écran
l'expérience globale immersive avec
l'audio la performance est notamment au
niveau du gaming
grâce au processeur de votre smartphone
et le quatrième point il faut que le
smartphone puisse durer dans le temps
sans que la batterie coupe lui faut donc
derrière une bonne autonomie et vous
allez voir que celui là ils cochent
l'ecal l'écran 54 pouces amoled foule
avait plus
2400 par 1080 pixels à 408 pixels par
pouces un écran qui occupent 98% de la
face avant avec un ratio vingt neuvième
et une colorimétrie 100% dci p3c un
smartphone qui est assez lumineux si
vous le pousser à fond vous arriver
jusqu'à 6 en it
alors attention ça bien consommer
davantage la batterie de votre
smartphone mais autant vous dire que
vous pouvez aller à l'extérieur ils vous
y voyez franchement claire un smartphone
qu'à une dalle oled ça veut dire fois ça
veut dire que dès lors que vous avez un
pixel noir et bien c'est un pixel est un
autant dire qu'il ne vient pas du tout
consommer d'énergie et un écran est
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
il a quelques paramètres que je
conseille à devenir utilisés notamment
la protection des yeux qui vient
légèrement devenir le mode de couleurs
de l'écran par défaut il est en mode
vivent c'est à dire 100 % des seuils p 3
vous pouvez passer en mode doux en srgb
personnellement le mode vie finira
parfaitement bien parce que je vous
conseille aussi c'est la protection des
yeux réduction des sentiments à faible
luminosité
le soir lorsque vous allez venir réduire
la lumière votre écran ça va venir
protéger vos yeux lutter contre la
fatigue oculaire c'est aussi pour moi un
point très important donc la première
partie qui concerne l'affichage pour
l'aspect multimédia pour moi elle
remplit sa fonction l'écran est bien de
bonne qualité après le seul truc qu'il
se peut qu'on aime ou pas c'est la
partie de l'encoche ici aujourd'hui la
mode en 2020 et plus aux petites roues
perforées au poids dû faire des choix
d'ailleurs dit mon commentaire est ce
que vous aimez ce système d'encoches en
v oui ou non pour démarquer en main mais
un autre point cosy extrêmement
important pour l'expérience multimédia
et bien c'est la partie audio la partie
audio est aussi très très très très
forte on a du fond alors on a un seul
haut parleur mono qui situe là mais je
peux vous assurer qu'il envoie du bois
là c'est très fort je m'appelle
extrêmement fort dès le baisser parce
que ça ne va plus rien entendre il est
donc ici c'est la seule et unique source
à la différence du néo et du pro qui ont
du son stéréo mais déjà croyez moi celui
là rien tout seul comme il est là il se
fait entendre et se font entendre
extrêmement fort mais en plus de ça vous
avez une prise jack que vous pouvez dire
utilisez vous débranchez votre casse
directement dans ce très facile
d'utilisation et ça marche bien à noter
qu'on a essayé du dolby atmos qui est
activé par défaut vous avez le choix
entre quatre modes le mode intelligent
théâtre jeux musique et si vous voulez
aller encore plus loin et vous utilisez
un casque idée regardez vous venez vous
le branchez est en mode musique vous
avez des égaliseurs intelligent
équilibré doux détail est fermé et si
vous voulez aller plus loin vous mettez
votre ego hydrographiques et vous venez
modifier vous directement vos bandes
c'est sûr qu'au cas ce qu'à la qualité
sera de bien
meilleure qualité que si vous avez votre
petit haut parleur l'a alors même si
effectivement il développe suffisamment
de puissance on reste quand même sort de
son médium médium grave médiums aigus ce
qui est normal vu la taille du haut
parleur on n'a pas non plus faire de la
magie là dessus et si vous avez un
casque bluetooth vous pouvez le
connecter grâce au bluetooth cinq points
de l'appareil blanc à se poser la
question de la performance
parce que oui la performance est
important pour le gaming
alors c'est vrai que d'une façon un peu
général si on veut pas un smartphone qui
rame c'est bien d'avoir un processeur
qui soit suffisamment puissant mais si
on reste vraiment dans cette idée d
usage et du multimédia
il vous faut quelque chose qui marche
bien pour le gaming alors ici vous avez
un des derniers processeurs de qualcomm
dans le milieu de gamme
c'est le snapdragon 765 gg pour gaming
autant vous dire que là dessus pour
gaming à quoi faire vous avez 8 gigas de
ram c'est de la lpddr2 atrix et vous
avez 128 go de stockage non expansible
ennuis fs 2.1
en plus vous avez une optimisation des
performances grâce à la technologie de
au pot qui s'appelle ufs plus qui vous
permettra d'avoir une lecture écriture
encore plus optimisée il faut savoir
qu'ici vous avez le même processeur que
dans le modèle neo dont le finepix de
neo pour venir jouer à des jeux c'est
fluide ça réponde bien ça marche bien le
seul truc au jt de pouvoir venir un
petit peu regretté monde waka venir
bloquer le haut parleur c'est vraiment
le petit bémol fait attention la manière
dont vous allez venir vous tenir votre
smartphone dans votre main la chine qui
ira très bien pour venir jouer à tous
vos jeux directement sur votre
smartphone et jodie une fois de plus on
n'est pas dans l'idée du light un peu
cheap on est vraiment dans l'idée du
light qui marche bien et là dessus vous
serez absolument pas déçu et si on veut
que l'expérience multimédia soit
complète ce qu'il vous faut derrière
c'est un smartphone qui soit très bon en
autonomie je sais pas si vous connaissez
au pot si vous connaissez le travail de
pau au niveau de la charge d'ailleurs
marqué le mois tout de suite en bas en
commentaire avant d'aller plus loin mais
tu es la pause marquée le c'est bon ok
au pot ici à une batterie de 4000 25
millions permet là où ils sont aussi
extrêmement fort c'est au niveau de
leurs charges qui s'appelle la voûte
charge et si vous avez de la voûte 4.0
ici c'est un bloc de charges de 30 watts
qui vous permettra de recharger de 3 % à
50 % en seulement 20 minutes
autant vous dire que ça va vite vous ne
prenez pas la tête à leur charge et vous
vous levez le matin vous n'avez plus
beaucoup d'autonomie vous le branchez
vous partez faire ce que vous avez à
faire vous revenez il est déjà bien
un plein et vous allez pouvoir garder
une journée facilement en l'état si vous
le charger à 100% c'est un smartphone
que vous allez pouvoir garder entre une
journée mis à deux jours en fonction de
vos usages
mais ce qui est pour moi extrêmement
rassurant avec un smartphone comme celui
là c'est que vous en avez toujours votre
blog de charge avec vous et quoi qu'il
se passe
en dix minutes un quart d'heure vous le
rende et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'autonomie et vous êtes
reparti pour un bonbon à noter qu'ici
vous n'avez pas de recherche amphi pour
la partie os on tourne sous call en os
alors je sais pas si vous connaissez
coloro s mais en tout cas je trouve
qu'il ya eu un très très beau travail
fait de la part de coppola dessus vous
avez beaucoup de possibilités pourrait
venir clooney des applications et
d'avoir en doute pouvait venir scinder
votre écran êtes pas mal de paramètres
notamment concernant l'affichage ça je
voulais montre tout à l'heure où avenir
à définir le style de vos icônes les
modifier comme vous le souhaitez
modifier l'état et les formes les
rendent plus rond plus grand plus tirée
d'un point de vue purement expérience
utilisateur sauf que au pot a vraiment
fait un bon boulot là dessus un autre
visage c'est extrêmement important au
niveau des smartphones ça se situe ici
c'est la partie photo vous avez à
l'arrière pas moins quatre capteurs
photos le tout premier vous avez entre
un ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels
touvre f 2.2 et une stabilisation
électronique en dessous c'est le
grand-angle 48 mégapixels c'est une sony
mx 5 186 ouvre à f
1.7 également une stabilisation
électronique vous avez en dessous is it
un capteur monochrome de 2 mégapixels ou
rêve 2.4 et tout en dessous juste là
c'est également un capteur de 2
mégapixels qui est là pour notre
portrait pour les facebook et ouvre à f
2.4 tandis qu'à l'avant plan qu'elle
juste ici dans sa petite encoche vous
avez une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels
couvre f 2.0
l'interface assez classique qui marche
bien ici on va pendant une fois on
appuie sur un côté on passe en ultra
grand-angle on enlevait son côté en x 2
up x 5 et au monde jusqu'en x 10 le mode
portrait le mode nuit qui marche bien et
notamment si vous avez un trépied vous
le mettez dessus s'offre un exploit de
45 secondes d'aller voir résultat c'est
quand même assez bluffant et le mode
vidéo est cool parce que vous avez ici
de l'ultra stabilisation vous appuyer là
ça vient vous activez l'ultra
stabilisation la faisait son capteur
principal
le 46e mégapixels il s'agit d'une
stabilisation électronique et pop qui
puisqu'ils si vous n'avez pas de
stabilisation optique et vous avez un
petit switch ici et tac
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on change
d'objectif ou passer sur l' ultra
grand-angle si vous voulez venir filmer
dans les modes de stabilisation vous
pourrez filmer en 1080p si par contre
vous souhaitez tout désactiver préfet
mais jusqu en 4k à 30 images par seconde
mais par contre là ça risque de bouger
un petit peu ce que je comptais c'est de
la m sur un trépied
je vous montre le résultat j'allais
faire un peu de vélo
[Musique]
photo prise avec le capteur principal ça
fonctionne on voit bien tous les nuages
on a bien les persos envoie en de vue en
tout cas les feuilles dans les arbres le
résultat est vraiment qualitatif la
gestion de la lumière de l'exposition
tout est vraiment très très très bien
maîtrisée des composants ultra
grand-angle c'est moins précis rien et
cramer pour autant dans le ciel ça
fonctionne on voit quand même différent
de colorimétrie entre l'ultra grand
temps les le capteur principal on est
innocentes avec un sous x 2 ça
fonctionne ici la pâte et l'objectif
donc c'est le capteur principal qui
vient zoomer dans l'image c'est somme
toute assez qualitatif dès qu'on arrive
sur le x 5 c'est beaucoup moins précis
on rajoute du bruit ça vient glisser on
le voit bien ici au niveau des arbres là
c'est complètement lycée et c'est pas
extraordinaire
de la même manière les 6es du bruit dans
le ciel c'est pas terrible et les qu'on
arrive sur le faut dit bon voilà on peut
le faire mais je vous déconseille
vraiment de le faire caméra principale
ça fonctionne c'est très très bien qu'au
niveau des nuages du ciel de la face à
tout ce que vous voulez luttera
grand-angle perd en précision mais sinon
ça fonctionne bien le x 2 et auquel fois
sont pas terribles et faut dix on oublie
la même manière capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 5 f10 la caméra
principale sur les fleurs et si vous
avez de l'intelligence artificielle qui
reconnaît que vous avez une plante on va
ici un petit défaut au niveau de la
gestion des hautes lumières mais rien de
bien des cônes en date bien le tout le
détail au niveau des pétales à ça
fonctionne l'ultra grand temps qu'une
fois de plus ou moins précis mais il
fait le taf
dès qu'on s'approche avec le foie de ses
clients voit bien quelle petite goutte
la qualité quand même vraiment la foi 5
ça fonctionne caméra principale l'ultra
grand angle fois de samba
on récupère du bruit voyez ci sur toute
cette partie là et le foie sain c'est
pas terrible récit des petits des
aberrations chromatiques on va regarder
si au niveau du dollar moi c'est pas
complètement dingue
la caméra de self il fonctionne vraiment
bien le traitement est très juste
personnellement sauf le rendu est
vraiment qualitatif au quotidien que le
mode portrait qui détour vraiment bien
tout le tour de la main et très juste
les cheveux c'est parfait il a eu un peu
plus de mal ici mais c'est pas anormal
et c'était aussi assez complexe comme
celle mais tous les doigts sont bien des
tours et et dans l'ensemble c'est
vraiment très très bien le mode nuit tu
assez impressionnant par contre parce
que là vous n'avez absolument aucune
lumière dans le studio
les volets fermés un lit
ray très léger liseré de lumière passe à
travers les volets mais dans laquelle il
fait noir
la gelée posé sur un pied on assure une
explosion de 45 secondes et regarder ce
qu'on ressent la effectivement il ya un
peu de bruit sur le fond et sur le perso
mais malgré tout ça marche et c'est
assez impressionnant la même chose posé
au sol il n'a pas réussi à faire le
point sur le perso mais malgré tout la
gestion de la lumière est quand même
plutôt bonne pour voir qu'on a pas de
lui dire justement dans la pièce même
photo tenu cette fois ci à la main d'une
exposition qui est plus courte il n'y a
pas réussi à faire le point sur le perso
il ya du bruit de partout en plus de ça
une technique intéressante qu'elle a
mise en place par au pot il vous envie
par moins de dix antennes réparties tout
autour du smartphone ça sert à quoi ces
dix antennes et bien en fonction de la
manière dont vous allez tenir votre
smartphone sur le haut sur le bas vous
pouvez bloquer le signal vos smartphones
de façon intelligente va deviner comment
vous allez tenir et va venir activée
quatre antennes ne sont pas bloqués là
où le signal sera le mieux ça vous
permet de mieux capter le réseau
il ya également la techno smart 5 g qui
vous permettra de basculer de façon
intelligente entre la 4g et la 5g bien
évidemment une fois place un registre à
disponible dans votre pays et une fois
que vous aurez souscrit à une offre 5 g
ça vous permettra d'économiser notamment
30 % d'autonomie puisque oui la 5g va
venir consommer davantage donc lorsque
vous n'avez pas besoin d'un usage 5g
hibou switch enquête gd vous ai beaucoup
besoin paf vous switchez de façon
intelligente en 5 j vous avez bien
évidemment du nfc une seule carte sim et
concernant le das on est à 0,86 watts
par kilogramme au niveau de la tête et
au niveau du tronc on est à 1,26 watts
par kilogramme où j'ai noté là dessus
ces chiffres sont un peu imbitable à
apprendre par coeur je voulais lire en
tout cas les informations sont bonnes
avec son swing big bud light au pot n'a
pas lésiné sur elle et techno que vous
avez sur les usages lorsque vous allez
pouvoir en faire je dis tout le côté
multimédia gaming réseaux sociaux photo
on a un smartphone qui marche très bien
qui est vraiment de bonne facture et
vous trouvez un tarif inférieur à 500
euros puisqu'il coûte 449 euros
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je vous ai
mis des liens en bas dans la description
a vous de me dire vous maintenant
comment vous trouvez ce au pot findings
de light
est-ce qu'il peut vous tentez est ce que
vous avez acheté le pro le neo ou même
déjà carrément light mark et moi tout ça
on va bien évidemment on commentaires
personnellement je trouve que c'est
vraiment intéressant
le découpage qui a eu au pot sur cette
gamme finepix 2 et c'est une vraie belle
le finepix de pro avec le neo vous avez
un produit qui est vraiment super tout
infléchissement de 90 art vous avez le
même processeur que dans le light est
une fois de plus je le dis il n'a de
light que le nom on a vraiment plein de
produits qui sont vraiment cool et que
je ne peux que vous recommander à vous
de me dire maintenant vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve demain pour
continuer à parler tech je vois beaucoup
d'amour à des mannequins
[Musique]
non
m